All day, it's the chita chat time. It's the chita chat time. Chitty chit chat chat. Ooh, Angela, is this our new intro to? We had one. We abandoned it. We did. We did.
整整一天，都是闲聊时间。这是闲聊时间。闲聊，闲聊，唠唠嗑。噢，安吉拉，这是我们的新开场白吗？我们之前有一个。我们放弃了。是的，我们放弃了。
You know what? I like the idea that we just cycle in a new one every once in a while. We just in the moment. If someone feels inspired to make up a single. Okay. All right. Should we get started? We should get started.
你知道吗？我挺喜欢这种每隔一段时间就换一个新的的想法。我们就凭当下的感觉。如果有人突然心血来潮想创作一小段。好吧。行吧。我们该开始了吗？我们该开始录了。
I did want to say this even last time. I didn't comment on it. Jenna, behind you, I don't know. They're leaves. Are they birds? They're things on the wall. They're fish, I think. They are fish, Sam, yes.
我其实上次就想说了。我当时没好意思评论。珍娜，你身后，我不知道。那些是树叶吗？是鸟吗？那是墙上的装饰。我想那是鱼。没错，萨姆，那是鱼。
Fish. Oh, yes. They are a series of 3D fish, tiny fish, golden fish. Art. They're all gold. And they are arranged and they're swimming in a circle. And this is the decor for above the fireplace. That you're renting while you're in Chicago.
鱼。哦，对。那是一系列3D小鱼，很小的金鱼，金色的。艺术品。它们全都是金色的。它们排列在一起，绕成一圈在游动。这就是壁炉上方的装饰。你在芝加哥租的房子里的装饰。
Is it cold enough? Have you used the fireplace yet? I have not. It is not. wood burning. Oh, okay. But I think it's gas and I think it could work. But no, it's been unseasonably warm here. Oh, really? Okay. As people are telling me, but it just turned cool. So, I don't know. I'm only here one more week. One week. Yeah. Oh, my gosh. We're going into our last weekend of the show. It's crazy. You must have lots of feelings about that. I do. I'm very
够冷吗？你用过壁炉了吗？我还没用过。还不够冷。那是烧木头的吗？哦，好吧。不过我觉得那是天然气壁炉，应该能用。但是没有，这里的天气异常暖和。哦，真的吗？好吧。大家都这么跟我说，不过刚开始变凉了。所以，我也不确定。我在这里只剩最后一个星期了。一个星期。对。哦，天哪。我们要迎来节目的最后一个周末了。太疯狂了。对此你一定有很多感触吧。确实有很多。我非常
excited to get home to my house and my kids and my life there. Right. Angela, I left you a message about this, about how, like, when you have quirks, when you're on location, you know this, Angela. You go on location and you have to live in a place that is not your home, that you don't have a lot of control over. Yeah. Like, I remember this one place I lived, the cutlery drove me absolutely bonkers. I hated it. I hated the cutlery. It was such a little thing, but I hated it.
高兴能回家回到我的房子、我的孩子们和我在那里的生活。没错。安吉拉，我为此给你发过一条消息，关于那种，比如说，当你有一些个人习惯，当你去外地出差时，你知道的，安吉拉。你去外地出差，必须住在一个不是你家的地方，一个你无法掌控很多东西的地方。对。就像，我记得我以前住过的一个地方，那里的餐具把我折磨得快要疯了。我讨厌它们。我讨厌那套餐具。虽然是很小的一件事，但我就是讨厌。
The knives didn't really cut anything. It drove me nuts. I got home from that, and I remember just like, loving my knives and being like, there you are, little nice that I picked out that I love with all my heart. I didn't even know I loved you so much. Well, here, the quirk is the placement of the light switches. And they drive me absolutely crazy. In order to turn on the light for the kitchen, it's by the front door. That's the only one? Yes. That's the only light for the kitchen. So I repeatedly walk in and then I walk into the kitchen and I realize, oh, dang it.
那些刀子根本切不动什么东西。把我折磨得够呛。从那儿回到家后，我记得自己简直是爱死我自己的刀了，心想：原来你们在这儿呀，我精心挑选的、我用整个心去爱的小刀们。我以前甚至都不知道我这么爱你们。好吧，在这里，让人不习惯的是电灯开关的位置。它们把我折磨得彻底疯狂。要想打开厨房的灯，开关居然在正门旁边。只有这一个吗？是的。那可以说是厨房唯一的灯光开关。所以我经常是走进来，然后走进厨房，才突然意识到：哦，该死。
The light is over the front door. And I have to turn back around. Likewise, once I've lit up the kitchen and I've cooked something and I want to turn off the lights and like maybe sit in front of the TV and watch something while I eat, I have to walk back to the front door. And it's not like it's that far. It's just illogical. It's just odd. It's just I want the light switch for the kitchen to be by the sink.
开关在正门那边。我又得转过身走回去。同样的，一旦我把厨房的灯打开，做好了饭，想关掉灯，然后可能坐在电视机前边吃边看点什么，我又得走回正门去。倒不是说有多远。就是很不合逻辑。就是很怪。我希望厨房的灯开关就在水槽旁边。
That's where I want. And if I lived here, I would call an electrician and I would say, will you please put a light switch to the kitchen in the kitchen? I love like kind of like a new place like that because there's always some little delicious treat waiting for you that you didn't think about. Like my friend Betsy is she's got a directing gig in Ireland, right? And so she's got this rental in Ireland right now. She's working on a show there.
那才是我想要的地方。如果我住在这里，我会叫个电工来，然后对他说：“你能把厨房的开关装到厨房里吗？”我其实挺喜欢那种新地方的，因为总有一些意想不到的小惊喜在等着你，那些你之前没想过的事情。就像我的朋友贝茜，她在爱尔兰有个导演的工作，对吧？所以她现在在爱尔兰租了个地方。她在那边参与制作一个节目。
And we decided to do a little FaceTime catch up. And as she's talking to us, me and all of our tennis gals, we're all looking at her. And we're like, is that half of a bird behind you? That's a lamp? And she goes, oh, yeah. Yeah, I don't know why. There's a bird thing happening here.
然后我们决定通过FaceTime小聚一下。当她跟我们说话时，我和我们网球俱乐部的小伙伴们都在看着她。我们就问：“你身后那是半只鸟吗？那是个台灯吗？”然后她说：“哦，对啊。对，我也不知道为什么。这里有个鸟类的装饰。”
And you guys, the feet of the lamp were like the stork. You know, like the feet. And then the long, skinny legs. And then the poofy butt with all these feathers. And then no head. Just the lamp shade. Is the head the light bulb? Is that where the head would be?
然后你们知道吗，那个台灯的底座就像是一只鹳。你知道的，就像那种脚。然后是又长又细的腿。接着是一个蓬松的屁股，上面长满了羽毛。然后没有头。只有灯罩。难道头就是灯泡吗？那是头部应该在的地方吗？
It's just a lamp shade. Yes. That's pretty great. But like, what happened? And you have little, you have gold fish. Fish. And the gold fish. and light switches in a place that I don't love.
它真的只有一个灯罩。对。挺酷的。但是，这到底是怎么回事？你那边有小金鱼。鱼。金鱼。还有我不太喜欢的灯光开关。
Well, there you go. We can't wait for you to come home. We're very excited. I'm excited, too. I have a request. Angela, I brought this up before. Oh, yeah. It's something I need.
好吧，就是这样。我们迫不及待想让你回家了。我们非常兴奋。我也很兴奋。我有个请求。安吉拉，我之前提过这个。哦，对。这是我需要的东西。
It's so, hi. You guys, this is so dorky. But will you please lead to us from your food journal? Oh, I would love that. I have to explain first, you guys. Okay. So Josh and I, you know, we have this cookbook coming out. You can make.
天哪，你们好。这听起来太书呆子气了。但是，你能给我们朗读一下你的美食日记吗？哦，我很乐意。我得先解释一下，伙计们。好吧。我和乔治，你们知道的，我们有一本要出版的食谱。你可以做。
this. And as part of it, we're doing all this press. And New York Magazine reached out to me to do a piece. It's like a five-day food journal for their piece called Grubb Street Diet. Oh, no. Do they know about your journals? Sam, Sam, it pays off. Oh, God. I'm trembling. It's so good. It's so good. And I need it. I like need a whole, you could write a whole book. Yeah. Okay. Please go. Anyway, Josh and I are dividing up some of these press requests because there's a lot of them and I'm so appreciative that people are getting excited about the cookbook, but I said, I'll take the food journal, babe. Okay, so I had to document like basically my day and what I ate for five days and anyway, in like sort of a journal type, whatever genre.
这道菜。作为宣传的一部分，我们要进行各种媒体采访。然后《纽约杂志》联系我写一篇文章。这是一个为期五天的美食日记，登在他们叫“格拉布街饮食”的专栏里。哦，不。他们知道你的日记习惯吗？萨姆，萨姆，这太值了。天哪。我浑身发抖。太棒了。太棒了。我太需要了。我简直需要整整一个，你可以出一整本书了。好吧。请继续。不管怎样，我和乔治正在分担一些采访请求，因为采访实在太多了，我很感激大家对这本食谱充满热情，但我说：“亲爱的，美食日记我来写吧。”好吧，所以我基本上得记录我的一天以及我连续五天吃的东西，总之是以某种日记的形式，不管是什么文体。
So here we go. I'm just going to read the first day. Read the first day. This comes out October 24th, by the way. put a link in our stories to it. All right. Tuesday, August 16th, 7 a.m. Hi, from a Southwest flight from Chicago to Burbank.
所以，我们开始吧。我只读第一天。读第一天。顺便说一句，这篇文章将于10月24日发布。我们会在动态里放一个链接。好的。8月16日，星期二，早上7点。嗨，来自芝加哥飞往伯班克的西南航空航班。
My husband did the early bird check-in thing. We boarded in Group A. He gets very excited about boarding in Group A. He says it's all about getting that overhead space. And let me tell you, we got a sweet spot for our carry-ons. We had a fun but short trip to see my BFF, Jenna Fisher, in the play Ashland Avenue. it was fantastic. She and the entire cast were amazing. We did, however, stay out way too late
我丈夫办理了早鸟优先登机。我们登上了A组。他对能登上A组感到非常兴奋。他说这全是为了抢到头顶的行李舱空间。老实说，我们的随身行李确实抢到了一个好位置。我们去看了我的闺蜜珍娜·费舍尔主演的话剧《阿什兰大道》，这是一次有趣但短暂的旅行。太棒了。她和整个演员阵容都太惊艳了。不过，我们昨晚确实在外面呆得太晚了，
last night, and I'm a little bit of a zombie this morning. So I realize this is probably an odd time to start a five-day food journal, but we're stuck on the tarmac with some kind of plain traffic jam, no Wi-Fi, and I brought my laptop, so I thought, why not get this going? Can I stop you right there? Can I just say one of my favorite parts of the Food Journal is that it starts with absolutely no descriptions of food. Yeah. We're 10 minutes into this. There's no food.
今天早上我有点像个僵尸。所以我意识到，现在开始写一份五天的美食日记可能不是个好时机，但我们被困在跑道上遇到了某种飞机交通堵塞，没有Wi-Fi，我带了笔记本电脑，所以我想，为什么不现在就开始写呢？我能打断你一下吗？我能说吗，美食日记最妙的部分之一就是，开头完全没有任何对食物的描写。对。我们已经聊了10分钟了。根本没有食物。
Okay. I was counting how many, yeah, counting how many sentences until you mentioned food and then I lost track. Well, well, well, here's the thing. You guys, they just said they wanted it to be slice of life. Okay. So not, not everything is you making a meal. It's about like your process of the day and where you ate, right?
好吧。我一直在数有多少，对，数到你提到食物中间隔了多少句话，然后我就数乱了。好吧，好吧，好吧，事情是这样的。伙计们，他们只是说希望内容能贴近生活。好吧。所以并不是，并不是每一部分都是你在做饭。而是关于你一天的生活过程，以及你在哪里吃饭，对吧？
Sometimes you're cooking at home. Sometimes you're going out. Yeah. But listen, if you read all five days, there's lots of meal eating. watching. Josh made a lot of recipes from our cookbook that are so good and I share all about that. And then I do have a lot of snacks. My nickname was Snacks Kinsey for a while. Your nickname was Snacks and Hambone at a certain point in your life? Snacks Kinsey. Oh, Snacks Kinsey. You got to get it right, Sam. Snacks Kinsey and Hambone. Okay. Because I always have snacks, always. Even right now I've got
有时候你在家做饭。有时候你出门吃。对。但是听着，如果你把这五天都读完，里面有很多吃大餐的内容。观看节目。乔治用我们的食谱做了很多好吃的菜，我在里面都分享了。然后我确实吃了很多零食。有一段时间我的绰号叫“零食金西”。你人生中的某个阶段，绰号叫“零食”和“火腿骨”？零食金西。哦，零食金西。你得说对，萨姆。零食金西和火腿骨。好吧。因为我总是随身带着零食，随时随地。甚至现在我都带着
some snacks. I love it. That is very true, lady. But listen, I know we have been teasing you, but I like genuinely, truly loved this food journal, like as a piece of writing. And I have been doing a ton of reading since I've been in Chicago. And this was one of my favorite things that I have read. Like in a long time, actually, it took me on a journey. It made me think about how food connects us with other people. I mean, the idea of the article is that you're supposed to describe five days of food in your life. But it just, it becomes so much more than that. And it's because you wrote it lady. And it's, I just love seeing five days of your life through your eyes, which is just, it's kind, it's funny, it's detailed, it's entertaining. I just loved it. Well, Jenna,
一些零食。我太喜欢了。这绝对是真的，女士。但是听着，我知道我们一直在逗你开心，但我真的，真心非常喜欢这篇美食日记，把它当成一篇文学作品来读。自从我来到芝加哥后，我一直在大量阅读。这是我读过的最喜欢的作品之一。其实好久没读到这么好的了，它带我踏上了一段旅程。它让我思考食物是如何将我们与其他人连接在一起的。我的意思是，这篇文章的构思是让你描述你生活中五天的饮食。但它不仅仅于此，意义深远得多。这全是因为它是你写的，女士。而且，我就是喜欢透过你的眼睛去看你生活的五天，既善良、有趣、充满细节，又极具娱乐性。我太喜欢了。好吧，珍娜，
thank you so much. That is a huge compliment coming from you. You are an avid reader. So I take that as high praise. And I'm excited for everyone to read it. I had a ton of fun. doing this. Josh says maybe, maybe I should write a book called journal entries and other things someday. We'll see. It's going to be great. I'm so excited. I'm hooked. Uh, thanks, you guys. And then Sam, Angela and I need to confront you about something. Uh-oh. I mean, confront sounds a bit sure, yeah. But I did that as like a tease to get people to sort of like, sit up straight. What are they going to say? Sam, do you have a podcast? You have a podcast? You have a podcast? You didn't even tell us about. I mean, I am, I am just like, what? Angela sends me a message. She's like, did you know about
非常感谢你。这对你来说是极高的赞誉。你可是一个博览群书的人。所以我把这视为对我的高度评价。我也很期待大家都能读到它。我写得非常开心。乔治说也许，也许有一天我应该写一本名为《日记摘抄及其他》的书。我们拭目以待。这一定会很棒的。我太激动了。我彻底迷上了。呃，谢谢你们。然后，萨姆，安吉拉和我有件事要质问你。噢哦。我的意思是，“质问”听起来有点，当然，是的。但我是用这个来当个悬念，好让大家坐直身子。他们要说什么？萨姆，你有一个播客？你居然有一个播客？你居然有一个播客？你甚至都没有告诉我们。我的意思是，我当时整个人就是，什么？安吉拉给我发了一条消息。她说：“你知道这件事吗？”我说：“我根本不知道。”萨姆，你有了播客得告诉你的阿姨们呀。我知道。好吧，我正在录制中，第一集快完成了。我刚官宣。我们最近没进录音室，不然我会在节目里提的。对，它叫《甜食》。是关于我对糖果的热爱的。第一集是关于M&M豆的历史。但是，公平地说，我看到了你发布的那段剪辑。内容大概是那样，但其中包含了，呃，我该怎么说呢，你那颠覆性的幽默感。是的。所以播客里有很多题外话。
this? I was like, I didn't know about it. Sam, you got to tell your aunties when you get a podcast. I know. Okay, I am in the process of recording that the first episode's almost done. I just announced it. We hadn't been in studio or I would have mentioned it on air. Yeah, it's called Sweet Tooth. It's about my love of candy. The first episode is about the history of M&Ms. But, but to be fair, I saw this clip that you posted. It is about that, maybe, but includes, um, how shall I say your subversive sense of humor. Yes. So there's lots of tangents on the podcast.
题外话。对。你知道我们最喜欢题外话了。呃，在某一集里，我打电话给一个婚姻律师，看看我能不能像皮维说的那样，在法律上和M&M豆结婚。有一点，我做到了。我差不多联系到了某个人，不过，我在给美国宇航局打电话时，层层转接，打到了挺高级别的部门。
Tangents. Yeah. You know we love a tangent. Uh, at one point I call a, uh, a marriage attorney to see if I could legally marry M&Ms like Peewe says to. At one point, I got it. I almost spoke to somebody, but I, I got pretty far up the ranks calling NASA.
我想知道如果挑战者号有糖衣，比如像M&M豆那样，它还会不会爆炸。萨姆，这话题太黑暗了。我知道。萨姆。这也太黑暗了。这就是我想说的。比如，这就是M&M豆的历史吗？
I wanted to see if the Challenger still would have exploded if it had a candy shell, like an M&M. Sam, that is so dark. I know. Sam. That is so dark. This is what I'm saying. Like, is it the history of Eminemps?
哦，我们确实非常简短地聊了M&M豆。我到底什么时候才能学到关于M&M豆的知识？是的，你会学到的。是的，弗雷斯特·马尔斯，也就是创造M&M豆的那个人，他通过观看美国内战中的士兵战斗，并吃这种在他们手里不会融化的巧克力，从而受到了启发，发明了M&M豆。然后他回到美国说：“我自己也能卖这个。”
Oh, we do talk about Eminemes very briefly. Am I going to learn about the Eminem at any point? Yes, you are. Yes, Forest Mars, Sr., the guy who created Eminem's, found Eminem's by watching Civil Revolutionary War, fighting and eating this chocolate that didn't melt in their hands. And then he came back to the U.S. and he said, I can sell that myself.
哇。你确定你想要这样吗？这可真是一个重磅猛料。嗯哼。好吧。对。《甜食》将在万圣节发布。哦，时机太完美了。
Wow. Are you sure you want to? That's a big nugget. Mm-hmm. Okay. Yeah. Sweet tooth comes out on Halloween. Oh, it's a perfect time.
完美的时机。所以我基本上希望每个小时都像是你在我的脑子里度过一个小时，看看我的大脑是如何运转的，比如想一个话题，想一个题外话。然后在我必须知道这个题外话的答案之前，我都无法回到最初的话题，之后我们才回到正事。好吧，萨姆式的兔子洞。对，没错。就像安吉拉的日记让我愉悦一样，你的大脑也让我感到愉悦。
Perfect timing. So I basically wanted each hour to be like you're spending an hour in my brain of how my brain works of like thinking of a topic, thinking of a tangent. And now I can't get back to that first topic until I have to know the, answer to this tangent and then we get back to work. Well, the Sam rabbit hole. Yeah, exactly. In the way that Angela's journaling delights me, your brain also delights me.
所以我很期待这个播客。太好了。卡西，我看到你参加了一个即兴喜剧节。是这样吗？真的吗？你参加了一个节日？滑稽小品节？我以为你参加了。
So I look forward to this. Good. Cassie, I saw that you did an improv festival. Is this right? Really? Did you, you did a festival? Sketch comedy festival? I thought you did.
你肯定会记得。你肯定会记得这个细节。你参加了多少个节日？对。我周五晚上要表演一个即兴喜剧秀，这是为了宣传一个崭露头角的D&D（龙与地下城）喜剧秀，我要在里面玩木偶戏。等等，等等，等等。玩木偶戏。
You would remember. You would remember this detail. How many festivals do you do? Yeah. I'm doing an improv show Friday night, and it is to promote an up-and-coming D&D comedy show that I'm in doing puppetry for. Wait, wait, wait. Doing puppetry.
别把最劲爆的内容藏在后面啊。对。我超爱木偶。这是现场舞台秀吗？对。详细说说。对。我想我以前在播客里没说过这个，但我有四分之一的日本血统，我是个喜剧团体的一员
Don't bury the lead there. Yeah. I love puppets. This is a live stage show? Yeah. Elaborate. Yeah. I don't think I've said this on the podcast, but I'm a quarter Japanese, and I'm part of a comedy group
名叫“亚裔美籍力量”（Asian A.F），里面全都是亚裔美国喜剧演员。我们其中一群人正在做一个D&D主题的秀。为了这个D&D秀，里面有一个地下城主。然后每个喜剧演员都在扮演、开发和饰演一个角色。我演的是一个术士。我提议弄一个木偶，因为我在大学时玩了很多木偶戏。而且我只是好久没玩了。所以我的衣柜里一直放着木偶。
called Asian A.F, which is all Asian American comedians. And a group of us are doing like a D&D show. And so for the D&D show, there's like a dungeon master. And then each comedian is playing, is developing and playing a character. And I'm playing a warlock. And I pitched doing a puppet because in college I did a lot of puppetry. And I just haven't done it in a long time. So I have like puppets sitting in my closet.
而且我有。卡西，你抖出了好多个人背景秘辛。爆了好多猛料。我都认识你十年了。你刚才居然轻描淡写地随口说了一句：“我在大学里玩过很多木偶戏。”继续，详细讲讲。对，对，对。我也演过很多舞台剧。
And I have like. So much Cassie lore that you're dropping. It was so many nuggets. I've known you a decade now. You just casually mentioned I did a lot of puppetry in college. Go on, elaborate. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I did a lot of like first age as well.
木偶是你自己做的吗？对，木偶是从哪来的？我有擅长制作木偶的朋友。我会帮他们，或者他们帮我做一个木偶，但缝纫可不是我的强项。所以更像是，我弄到一个木偶，然后根据它创造一个角色。你怎么操控木偶？就像吉姆·汉森的那种风格。
Do you build the puppet yourself? Yeah, where do the puppets come from? I have friends that are really good at building puppets. I would help them or they'd help me build a puppet, but that's like sewing is not my forte. So it's more like I get a puppet and then create a character off of it. How do you hold the puppet? It's like Jim Henson style.
就像一个毛毡木偶，然后你用左手操控手臂，右手操控头部。太神奇了。真的很可爱。我们能听听你用的那个角色的声音吗？不行。不行？不行。什么？拜托。拜托。我发给你，我发一段我模仿那个角色的剪辑吧，老实说，我好久没用这个声音了，所以我得排练一下，找回那种感觉。我完全尊重这一点，特别是如果它就像木偶戏的一部分一样，不过我真的很想看。我不认为自己是一个奇怪的木偶戏纯粹主义者，但我确实觉得，除非木偶在手上，否则我就不会去演那个角色。我尊重这一点。对。如果桑尼在场，我能把桑尼的声音模仿得好得多，因为我真的
like a felt puppet and then you use your left hand to operate the arms and then you do the head. That is amazing. It's really cute. Can we hear preview of the voice you use? No. No? No. What? Come on. Come on. I'll send you, I'll send like a clip of me doing the character, but I honestly haven't done the character in so long that I have to like rehearse it and get it to come back to me. I totally respect that and especially if it's part of the puppetry like in you I would love to see it though. I don't like consider myself like a weird puppet tearing purist, but I do feel like I don't do the character unless the puppets like on. I respect that. Yeah. I do a much better sunny voice if sunny is there because I'm
在模仿他。对。如果只是我一个人自言自语，要模仿他的声音就难多了。珍娜，让我问你一个关于宠物的问题。聊天室里有谁养过宠物并带它们坐过飞机吗？哦，对。我以前经常带我的猫安迪坐飞机，安迪。抱歉。安迪。他当时就是这么发音的。
really channeling him. Yeah. It's harder for me to do his voice when I'm just like by myself. Jenna, let me ask you a sunny question. This is open to anybody in the chat with pets. Has Has anybody ever flown with their pet before? Oh, yeah. I used to fly with my cat, Andy, Andy. Sorry. Andy. Andy is how he pronounced it.
而且我觉得他有一点法国血统。我不太确定。有点法国血统。对。我也带桑尼坐过飞机。我把宠物背包背在肩上。两周后我要带着拉面第一次飞回密尔沃基老家了。它其实并不喜欢它的背包。
And I think he was part frange. I'm not sure about it. It was a little fronch. Yeah. And I've flown with Sunny as well. I've got the carrier over my shoulder. I'm flying home to Milwaukee with Raman for the first time in two weeks. And he does not like his carrier.
它从来没进去过。所以，我想问，你之前让你的猫习惯过背包吗，或者你有什么坐飞机的建议吗？你给安迪吃过镇静剂吗？我没有给它吃镇静剂。安迪从小就经常待在背包里旅行，你知道的，跟我一起坐车去大学，一路去到洛杉矶，后来我也经常带它坐飞机回家。所以它其实挺适应的。桑尼也是经常去兽医诊所什么的。所以，没有，我没有做什么背包适应训练。那可真有点难。不过你可以去问问你的兽医，因为
He's never been in one. So, like, I was going to ask, did you introduce your cat to the carrier beforehand or like do you have any flying advice did you medicate andy i did not medicate them andy had traveled so much in his carrier from the time he was little you know to and from college with me all the way out to l.A and then i would fly home with him so he was pretty comfortable and sunny just go into the vet and stuff so no i didn't do any kind of like carrier training that's that's a tough one i talk to your vet about it though because okay you know You definitely don't want Raman to be super stressed.
你绝对不希望拉面压力太大。压力太大，对。我觉得对我的宠物来说，压力最大的部分是当你通过安检时，你必须把它们从背包里拿出来，然后把背包过安检机。接着你要抱着它们走过金属探测器门。然后再把它们放回背包里。有一次，安迪突然猛冲出去了。真的吗？挣脱了？
Stressed, yeah. I think that the most stressful part for my pets is that when you go through security, you have to remove them from the carrier and put the carrier through. And then you carry them like through the metal detector thing. And then put them back into the carrier. And one time, Andy bolted. Really? Got loose?
对。它挣脱了。然后，当然了，大家都很热心地想帮忙。所以他们都在追它。但我喊着：“不，不，不。它只让我抱它。别去追那只猫。”当然，最后我把它抓回来了，但那真是一次惊险的冒险。好吧。哎呀。对。我最近坐飞机时，看到有位女士带了一只猫，那只猫是长毛灰色的，全身都是灰的那种猫，你知道吗？哦，当然，是的。然后它们，她把它放在
Yep. He got loose. And then, of course, people are trying to be helpful. So they're chasing him. But I'm like, no, no, no. he'll only let me pick him up. Don't chase the cat. So, of course, I got him back, but that was an adventure. Okay. Yikes. Yeah. I was on a plane recently, and there was a lady that had a, the cat was like the long-haired gray, all-gray kind of cat, you know? Oh, sure, yeah. And they were, she had it in the
背包里，正沿着过道走过来，一路上，你只能听到这只猫在叫。听起来就像是：喵，对。我当时想：哦，老兄。我四五年前去过纽约。来回我都转机了。所以总共坐了四次飞机。四次航班我旁边都坐着一只狗。不是吧。那是我生命中最美好的一天。你去买彩票了吗？
carrier and was walking down the aisle and the whole way down, you just heard this cat. And it was just like, me, yeah. I was like, oh, buddy. I went to New York four or five years ago. I had a connecting flight both directions. So four total airplanes. I sat next to a dog, all four flights. No. It was the best day of my life. Did you go buy a lottery ticket?
没有。对，没错。太不可思议了。有一件事，卡西，你的D&D节目让我想起了一件事。我的表弟韦德——向德克萨斯州奥尔尼的韦德致敬——今天早上给我发了这个。他说：“安琪，看我今天买了什么。”他玩万智牌。哦，我知道这个。
No. Yeah, exactly. It was incredible. One thing, Cassie, your D&D thing made me think of something. My cousin, Wade, shout out to Wade in All-Nee, Texas sent me this this morning. He said, Ange, look what I bought today. He plays Magic the Gathering. Oh, I know about this.
我知道有一个，是不是德怀特系列？德怀特。对，就像是一个万智牌的德怀特系列，对。我的意思是，雷恩知道这个吗？看，珍娜，这整套。他知道。他知道。对，我和他聊过这个。真的吗？哇。嗯哼。对。太不可思议了。哦，伙计们，说到雷恩，我不得不聊聊他的电影《代号3》。哦。对，我看到你在社交媒体上发关于它的动态了。真的太棒了。感觉真的很奇妙。非常搞笑，但又无比真诚和可爱。一点也不愤世嫉俗。我太喜欢了。片名叫什么来着？《代号3》。特别是如果你喜欢《急诊室的故事》。对。好吧。这部电影之于急诊室的
know that there's a like a whole, is it Dwight? Dwight. Yeah, it's like a Dwight series of The Gathering, yeah. I mean, does Rain know this? Look, Jenna, that's a whole. He does know. He knows. Yeah, he, I talked to him about it. Really? Wow. Mm-hmm. Yeah. That's incredible. Oh, guys, speaking of Rain, I have to talk about his movie Code 3. Oh. Yeah, I saw you post on social media about it. It is so good. Like, it's truly wonderful. It is so funny, but it is so earnest and lovely. It is not cynical. I loved it. What's it called again? Code three. Especially if you love the pit. Yeah. Okay. This movie is like what the pit is to like emergency room
医生和护士们，就如同《急诊室的故事》之于他们一样。这部电影是关于急救医疗人员的。紧急医疗救护人员，对。就像他们是，另一个词叫什么来着？急救护理人员。对，谢谢。雷恩在里面饰演一名急救护理人员，你能看到急救护理人员一整天的生活，整整24小时。对。而且，天哪，真的太棒了。它比《急诊室的故事》更好笑，但又保留了《急诊室的故事》那种极其人性化的元素。对。所以向雷恩致敬，拍了这部好电影。
doctors and nurses and everything. This is to EMTs. EMTs, yeah. Like they are the, what's the other word for them? Paramedic. Paramedics. Yes. Thank you. And Rain plays a paramedic and you get to see a whole day in a paramedic's life, like a full 24 hours. Yeah. And it is, oh, God, it's so good. And it's like, it's funnier than the pit, but it has that element of the pit where it's just so human. Yeah. So shout out to Rain for that.
编剧是帕特里克·皮安涅扎（Patrick Pianneza）和克里斯托弗·莱昂（Christopher Leone），导演是克里斯托弗·莱昂。我总是喜欢感谢编剧和导演。太棒了。已经加入我们的片单了。既然我在给电影打call，伙计们，还有一件事。自从我来到芝加哥，而我的孩子们和李留在洛杉矶上学后。每天晚上演完话剧回家后，我都得消磨大约90分钟的时间来放松身心。
It was written by Patrick Pianneza and Christopher Leone and directed by Christopher Leone. And I always just like to shout out the writer and director. Yeah. Great. It's in our cue. And since I'm shouting out movies, guys, here's another. thing. Since I've been in Chicago and my kids have been back in L.A. with Lee going to school. Every evening after I do the play, I come home and I have to kill like 90 minutes while I wind down.
所以我看了好多节目。看了好多电影。在洛杉矶我从来没有时间做这些。所以我要给另一部电影打call：《破产》。我不知道你们有没有听说这部电影。由怀亚特·拉塞尔（Wyatt Russell）和奥登·桑顿（Auden Thornton）主演。同样地，非常迷人，充满人性光辉，演技精湛。讲的是一个骑野马的牛仔以及这项运动对他的身体造成的影响等等。所以他是个罗德奥牛仔，四处奔波参加骑野马比赛。这部电影叫什么名字来着？叫《破产》。《破产》。好吧。由卡利斯·尤班克（Carlis Eubank）编剧和导演，真的非常非常好看。这就是我的一点电影安利。我还读了超级多书。你听起来越来越像泰勒·斯威夫特了。你今天看到她的预告片了吗？就是《时代巡回演唱会》电影要上映的那个预告？没有。还有另一部电影要上映。我和我女儿一起去看了她的歌舞片首映。12月份要上映了，而且，女士，里面全都是他们是如何筹备《时代巡回演唱会》的幕后花絮。有一个镜头是她。她卸掉了所有的妆。
So I have watched so many shows. I have watched so many movies. I never have time for this in L.A. So I'm going to shout out another movie. Broke. I don't know if you've heard of this movie. Stars Wyatt Russell and Auden Thornton. Absolutely again, so charming, so human, beautiful acting. It's about a guy who rides Broncos and like the effect that it's having on his body and everything. So he's like a rodeo cowboy and he's going around and doing the Bronco ride. And what was it called again? It's called Broke. Broke. Okay. And it's written and directed by Carlis Eubank and it's very, very good. Those are my little movie shoutouts. I've also read tons of books. You're sounding a lot like Taylor Swift. Did you see her trailer today? The end of the
然后她说：“好吧，基本上，为了从那场表演中缓过来，我不得不看好几个小时的电视和电影什么的。”是的。然后我想到了你。我就想：好吧，珍娜和泰勒。我们有太多共同点啦。我们有好多话可以聊呢。我们可以聊聊各自的放松日常。
Ares Tour, like movie that's coming out? No. There's another movie coming out. I went to her showgirl launch movie thing with my daughter. It's coming out in December and lady, it's all the behind the scenes of how they did the Ares Tour. There's a shot of her. She's taken off all her makeup.
你们俩应该一起去巡演。我们真的应该去。对，你们真应该一起去巡演。你知道吗？我会把它写进日记里。然后卡西来表演木偶戏，萨姆则会做一个超级，类似于那种尖锐风格的播客来记录。哦，伙计们，这太棒了。
And she's like, well, basically, for me to wind down from that performance, I have to watch like hours of like TV and movies and stuff. Yes. And I thought of you. I was like, well, Jenna and Tate. We have so much in common. There's so much we could talk about. We'll talk about our wind down routine.
嘿，在我们离开之前还有一件事。十月是乳腺癌宣传月。对。我意识到，正好是一年前，我向全世界公开了我的乳腺癌诊断结果。随着这个纪念日的到来，我一直在反思。我想借此机会，再次鼓励大家一定要去做自我检查，去做乳房X光筛查。你可以做这样一个测试，输入关于你自己的所有个人信息，
You guys should tour together. We really should. Yes, you guys should do a tour together. And you know what? I'll journal about it. And Cassie will do the puppet show and Sam will do a really sort of like, edgy podcast about it. Oh, guys, this was wonderful.
这样如果你不到40岁，仅凭你的家族病史，你也可能有资格进行乳房X光筛查。去做这个真的非常重要，因为在我为此进行的公益宣传工作中，我遇到了太多不到40岁就被诊断出患有乳腺癌的女性。所以这不仅是我们这些年长的女士才需要注意的。千万不要忽视任何身体异常，这一点真的超级重要。顺便提一句，去查查你的结肠镜，做个皮肤检查。就，全身都检查一遍。因为100%的早期发现才是我能够接受治疗、为什么我现在能来芝加哥演话剧并过着最好生活的原因。真的，千真万确。不过是的，今年发生了好多事。哦，我想我可以，我来更新一下近况。我完成了赫赛汀输液。我把输液港取出来了。对，珍娜，
Hey, one more thing before we go. October is Breast Cancer Awareness Month. Yes. I'm realizing that it was one year ago that I revealed my breast cancer diagnosis to the world. And with this anniversary, I've been reflecting a little bit. I want to just take this moment to, again, encourage people to please go do their self-exams, get their mammograms. You can do this test where you kind of enter in all this information about yourself
我正想问，如果你不介意和我们分享的话，你现在这段旅程进行到哪一步了？当然，可以。所以，除了五年的他莫昔芬（这是一种激素阻断剂）治疗之外，我已经完成了所有的治疗。这个药的作用是阻止我的身体吸收雌激素。所以基本上我就像一个生活在中世纪时代的更年期女性。我没有任何激素支持。我只能咬紧牙关硬挺过去。不过我已经吃了一年了。
so that if you're under 40 years old, you might qualify for a mammogram just based on your family history. and that's really important to do too, because in my advocacy work around this, I have met so many women under the age of 40 who are being diagnosed with breast cancer. And so it's not just for us older ladies. It's just really important not to ignore anything. And just in that vein, like get your colonoscopy, do your skin check. Like, just check it all. Because 100% early detection is why I was able to get treated and why I'm now off in Chicago doing a play and living my best life. So for sure, for sure. But yeah, a lot has happened this year. Oh, I guess I can I'll give an update. I finished my Herceptin infusions. I got my port out. Yeah, Jenna,
干得漂亮。完成20%了。太棒了。我适应得挺好的。我觉得我之所以适应得好，是因为我在坚持举重。对。所以如果有哪位女士正在收听，对吧，萨姆？
I was going to say, where are you at now in this journey if you don't mind sharing with us? Sure, yeah. So I'm done with all of the treatment except for the five years of Tamoxifen, which is a hormone blocker. And what that does is it blocks my body from absorbing estrogen. So basically I'm like a woman in menopause in medieval times. Like I don't get any hormonal support. I just have to just white knuckle my way through it. But I've been on it for a year.
我知道我们交流过关于举重的心得。没错。如果有任何女士即将开始服用他莫昔芬，或者正在经历他莫昔芬治疗。我强烈推荐举重。我也推荐针灸，针灸对我的潮热症状有极大的缓解作用。还有，很遗憾地说，避免摄入糖分和酒精也真的帮我缓解了潮热，而且严格遵守我的睡眠时间表也至关重要。真的，充足的睡眠对于我能够忍受药物的一些副作用来说太重要了。
Way to go. 20% finished. Nice. I'm tolerating it pretty well. I think I'm tolerating it well because of the weight lifting that I'm doing. Yeah. So if there's a lady out there, right, Sam?
而且，是的，在情绪上，情绪是一个很大的课题。我在演话剧的时候把乳腺癌和所有这些都抛到脑后了。但现在我正准备回洛杉矶，这件事又浮现在我脑海里了。我又得去做下一轮的扫描检查了，所有的复查，所有的医生预约，所有这些事情——它就是会发生。就好像我之前得到了一个喘息的机会。我想这就是我一直在和许多女性朋友讨论的事情，那就是当治疗结束时，其实并没有真正结束。真的没有所谓的终点。余生你都将是一名乳腺癌患者。你的余生都将受到监测。而且，一旦你经历过那种你以为会是“你挺过来了，你没事了，明年再来”的例行
I know we've traded messages about weightlifting. That's all right. And there's any ladies out there who are about to start a Tamoxifen journey or on a Tamoxifen journey. I highly recommend weightlifting. I also recommend acupuncture that has helped my hot flashes so much. Also, I'm sorry to say, avoiding sugar and alcohol has also really helped me with the hot flashes and being really, really strict about my sleep schedule. Like, really sleeping is so important
复查。一旦你经历过那种复查却得到了坏消息，它就会在你心里留下一个阴影，让你觉得：哦，坏消息是有可能的，至少对我有这个可能，你会想：哦，我的结果可能会不好。我想我以前总是把一切视作理所当然。我不知道。总之，我心里有点焦虑。当然。不过这就是我的近况总结，大家。但我告诉你们一个好消息。我真的很高兴。我真的
to me being able to tolerate some of the side effects of the drug. And yeah, I emotionally, emotionally is a whole thing. I forgot about the breast cancer and all of it while I was doing this play. But now that I'm getting ready to come back to L.A., it's on my mind again. I have to go get my next round of scans again, all the checkups, all the doctor's appointments, all the stuff like it happens. It's like I got this break. And I think that's the thing that I've been talking to a lot of women about, which is that when the treatment ends, it doesn't end. Like, there really is no end. You are a breast cancer patient for the rest of your life. You will be monitored for the rest of your life. And also, like, once you've gone to one of those sort of like routine
很开心。我真的在过着我最好的生活。我觉得整个经历让我与身边的人贴得更近，也让我更清楚生活中什么才是最重要的。这太棒了。总的来说，我真的很感恩。好吧，谢谢大家的聆听。谢谢。好的。当然。哦，等等，在我们离开之前，在我们离开之前，安琪，我想跟听众们分享一个我们想到的关于《办公室秘书》某一集的点子，这个灵感来自于周五闲聊。好吧，是这样的。我们想做一期节目，一期纯粹的《办公室秘书》闲聊特辑，邀请一位神秘嘉宾（待定），我们想和你们一起闲聊。
appointments that you just expect to be like, you did it, you're fine, come back next year. Like, once you've gone to one of those appointments and gotten bad news, it just creates this little part of you that you're like, oh, bad news is possible, at least for me, where it's like, oh, I could have a bad result. And I think I'd just always taken for granted. I don't know. So anyway, I've got a little anxiety there. Sure. But that's my recap, everybody. But I'll tell you the big news. I'm really happy. I'm really
我们希望你们大家也能参与进来。所以我们让伊莱亚娜（Ileana）在《办公室秘书》网站上建了一个文件夹，我想大概叫“闲聊点子”吧，因为我们要根据你们的建议来聊天。不是那种关于剧情的建议，而是纯粹的闲聊、贴近生活、生活碎碎念的建议。安吉拉，你会发一个向上滑动链接的动态吧？对的，我会在我们的Ins快拍里发一个向上滑动链接。我迫不及待想听到你们的想法了。这一定会非常有趣。
happy. I am really living my best life. And I feel like the whole experience brought me closer to people and closer to what's important to me in life. That's great. I'm really grateful ultimately. So, well, thanks for listening, everybody. Thank you. Yeah. Yeah, of course. Oh, wait, before we go, before we go, Um, Ange, I want to tell people about our idea that we had for an Office Ladies episode that is inspired by Friday Chit Chats. Okay, here it is. Um, we want to do an episode, a full chit chat episode of Office Ladies with a special guest, TBD, and we want to chit chat with you.
好了，伙计们，这就是我们今天的周五闲聊。干得漂亮。行啦。祝大家一周剩下几天过得愉快，我爱你们。再见。
We want you guys involved. So we asked Ileana to make a folder for the Office Ladies website called, I believe, chit-chat ideas because we are going to chit-chat off of your suggestions. So not like episode suggestions, but just chit-chat, slice of life, slice of life suggestions. And Angela, you will put a swipe up, right? Yes, I will put a swipe up in our Insta stories. I can't wait to hear from you guys. This is going to be so much fun.
到时候见。回头见。回头见。感谢收听《办公室秘书》。《办公室秘书》是Audacy呈现的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。Audacy的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。
All right. Well, guys, that's our Friday chit-chat. Yeah. Well done. All right. You guys have a great rest of the week. week and I love you. Hi.
《办公室秘书》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《鲁珀特里》。这期节目暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
See you then. See you later. See you later. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
回头见。待会儿见。待会儿见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛公司（Audyssey）的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制作人是兰斯利·布比科。奥德赛公司的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Ruppertry》。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。